good morning and welcome to today's
covet update we'll start by heading over
to minister adrian dix in vancouver
good morning my name is adrian dix i'm
bc's minister of health i'm joined here
in vancouver by the honorable jennifer
whiteside the minister of education and
in victoria by dr bonnie henry bc's
provincial health officer uh minister
whiteside and myself are honored to be
here on the territories of the muslim of
the squamish of the slave tooth first
nations were honored to be here on their
land uh dr henry is on the territory of
the luang and speaking people the
sangies and the esquimalt first nations
in today's briefing dr henry will be
speaking first about
the bc's response to the coven 19
pandemic and the pandemic and a number
of issues arising from that today and
then minister whiteside will give an
update on
the cove 19 pandemic and the education
system the restart of schools and then
i'll finish with an update on a number
of issues and then we'll be taking your
questions so with that it's my honor as
always to introduce dr bonnie henry
and good morning thank you very much as
i don't need to say uh today sars ko v2
or what causes covet 19 continues to
persist
to evolve and of course to surprise us
in many ways
we cannot predict with certainty exactly
what is going to happen and we've seen
that as things have evolved over this
last two years
but we can and we must
make educated or informed
guesses or decisions based on the
imperfect information we do have
it's not mathematical certainty but it
is based on the best information that we
have
best information from what we know from
history around different coronaviruses
and other infections around immunology
and around what we're seeing around the
world
it is the best information we have but
it is by
necessity imperfect and in that context
that is where we are moving ahead now
with how we are going to manage to get
through this next wave the omicron wave
here of the pandemic
we have all seen that the virus
continues to spread that omicron is
spreading very rapidly and i said last
time that
where we had one or two generations of
separation now everybody i believe knows
somebody or has somebody in their close
social circle who's been affected by
covet 19.
that means this is going to be a
challenging month but it doesn't mean
that we need to stop everything we know
that the basics of foundations of what
we have in place the things that we have
learned to do
and the measures that we have in place
currently
are going to help us get through this
month
as we've done since the beginning of the
pandemic almost two years ago our goal
is to mitigate the impact of this virus
to make sure we're doing our best to
stop sickness and death to make sure
we're supporting our health care system
so everybody can get the care they need
and to minimize the negative impacts of
everything that we're doing on society
so we all need to continue to work
together in this storm in this version
of the storm that we're facing right now
and as we've done in the past we know
that we have the means and the
foundation for how to get through this
this omicron wraith while some things
are different with shorter incubation
period which means some of those tools
that we've relied on we can no longer
use effectively
but much remains the same
staying home staying away from others if
we're sick wearing a mask marrying a
good fitting mask especially when we're
around others
vaccination vaccination has made it a
different storm in many many ways and it
means that the impact can be mitigated
in all of us it protects us it protects
our families it protects our communities
so making sure that everybody has their
first and second dose and as we uh as
you're eligible get getting your booster
dose
keeping your distance from others in
those places where we don't know people
especially indoor places washing our
hands regularly keeping our gathering
small making sure we are using the
orders that are in place to to mitigate
and to prevent transmission in some of
the highest risk settings
earlier this week i spoke as well about
the importance of businesses
reactivating the covet safety plans that
was a strategy that we used very on
early on in this pandemic to really
develop specific strategies for each
specific business or industry and these
worked these helped us get through the
last number of waves and they will help
us get through this one too it becomes
more and more important as we're seeing
that increased transmission in our
communities and these safety plans are
measured to allow you to keep operating
in the face of a significant portion of
of workers who may be unable to come in
because they're what they're ill
themselves now with covid
it is important that every business take
this step now which is why today i'm
putting an order in place requiring
scovid safety plans for all businesses
in british columbia
worksafebc we've been working with
many different industry tables and had
many discussions over the past week or
so
and worksafe bc is working with us in
partnership again on these and has
reactivated their supports for
businesses and is available to address
your questions
as an employer we know that you have an
obligation to do all you can to keep
your employment environment safe and
your employees safe and i know the vast
majority of businesses have stepped up
without hesitation and many have
continued all of the measures from their
covet 19 safety plans from the previous
iterations
this is about activating all of those
layers of protection again to reduce the
impact of the omicron circulation in our
communities and making sure we can
continue to operate our businesses it's
about business continuity and we know
that this has proven to work to keep
businesses open and to safely manage
this order is specific to industry and
businesses and of course does not apply
um as it didn't in the previous
iterations to child care or
post-secondary or the k-12 where we have
additional other uh plans in place that
are unique to those settings
these are the plans that saw us through
up to now includes things like barriers
and reduced crowding and making sure we
can
reduce the mixing of staff if need be
working from home if that's possible and
facilitating workers staying home if
they are ill
these are the things that will work
again this time
this week our k-12 school communities
have been working hard to put enhanced
protocols in place and to plan for how
we're going to weather this storm and
ensure that we're able to provide those
essential educational services to our
children across bc
and i want to give my gratitude and
thanks to all of the educators and
school staff and parent groups and
families across the province for what
you have done
in this past week putting things
together and will continue to do as all
students are returning to classrooms
next week
it is essential and it's a priority for
all of us that we keep schools open and
functioning for our children
it's also important to remember that the
structured settings that we have in
school have been proven to be places
where they can learn and interact with
others and have that important emotional
physical and intellectual growth and
development in a way that is
safe for everybody in that setting
and safer than many of the unstructured
settings that children are in outside of
the school environment
we know that there's a lot of anxiety
and it is
always a challenge when we have more
illness in our communities how that's
going to affect schools and we've been
working very hard this week to make sure
that we have contingency plans in place
for if staff are ill if educators are
ill and for students and public health
will be working as we have with all of
our schools and our school districts to
make sure that we can support you in the
safe return to full classes starting
next week
having said that it's always going to be
a challenge and we're going to have to
adapt to things as they arise
i know that many parents are anxious
about children coming back to school
particularly if you have vulnerable
family members at home
and i just want to reassure you reassure
you that the things that we have in
place will do our best to mitigate any
of the challenges that we have
and it's important to remember as well
we have very high rates of immunization
in school staff and i encourage all the
children who are eligible
in schools now to get vaccinated as well
school
is essential and we know it is the best
place for children to be and i know that
the educators and school staff around
the province are very excited to welcome
children back into our schools next week
we've also seen the remarkable
resilience and adaptability of our
school communities and i know that's
what is going to help us get through
which we will undoubtedly be some rocky
times in the next few weeks
on december 21st we laid out in in some
more detail our plan for our expanded
use of rapid antigen tests here in bc
and we've said that we focus on
particularly through to the middle or
end of january that we're going to be
focusing on five key areas making sure
that we're supporting long-term care our
test sample
collection sites are testing sites and
that has been incredibly important as
many people have noted in the past few
weeks as we reached our our capacity
both from testing from the lab equipment
from
the personnel and
the reagents we know that pcr testing is
the most accurate but it has has a limit
and we've reached that limit in british
columbia it's still an important measure
and pcr testing needs to be
used for those where it makes a
difference in terms of their clinical
management i'll talk a little bit more
about that in a minute but because we've
had the rapid antigen tests of the
various different types of tests that
we've had here in bc we've been able to
supplement our testing sites with the
rapid antigen testing and that has
enabled us to make sure that people who
do need a test can get access
we're using them as well for health care
workers in acute care settings in remote
rural indigenous and and other more uh
vulnerable communities to make sure that
we can tell when omicron in particular
is entering those communities and
support those communities and taking
actions and of course we've been using
them in an ongoing way which we are
expanding in businesses and other
organization
there has been significant progress
deploying these tests since we talked
about that and i will
defer to minister dix to give you some
more of these details but just to say
that we have deployed close to 100 000
to long-term care to support long-term
care facilities
to testing sites we're now over 400
close to a half a million tests
supporting our testing sites across the
province
and we've got many out to rural remote
communities working with the first
nations health authority
so the tests that we have have been
moving out they are all accounted for
and we are continuing uh to access
tests for businesses and organizations
as we get more of them in
as well we are using rapid tests to help
us understand where oat breaks out
breaks and clusters are happening
including being able to support our k-12
system in the in the coming weeks on
outbreak management under the direction
of the medical health officers as we
have been doing
we do expect that additional rapid tests
will be available
you've heard the announcement from the
federal government a portion of those
tests will be coming to british columbia
but let me make it clear they are not
here yet
and when they begin to arrive there are
many different types of tests that will
be arrived some of them will be suitable
for self-administration the lateral flow
tests and
the at-home tests those are the ones
that we have been waiting for for some
time and as they arrive we will be
deploying them again
starting with our priority areas and one
of those priority areas of course will
be to support
continuing in-school education in the
k-12 system
we'll be starting when they start to
arrive late next week we're hearing
for
being able to test symptomatics teachers
and school staff
and in schools across the province and
the ministry of health and education and
bccdc and school districts are working
together
starting this week and until these
arrive to make sure that we have the
systems in place to be able to do that
and the protocols for self-testing
it's our expectation subject to more of
these uh these
at-home tests being available that we'll
be able to expand that in our school
communities and i've talked about this
for some months being able to provide it
for kids for children who are
symptomatic
in the school system and eventually as
we get more available tests
to be able to support families to do the
tests at home
on symptomatic members of the family of
the children to determine whether they
should be going to school or not we have
made significant progress deploying
these tests despite
challenging winter weather and all the
other things that have been thrown at us
over this holiday season and we're
continuing to break down the many tests
that we have that come in kits that are
too large to be used
in an individual basis and replacing the
nasal pharyngeal swabs with the nasal
swabs that are needed for a number of
the different types of settings that we
have
we expect our supply of tests to
increase in the weeks ahead and just
yesterday we were advised by canada that
we're getting a number in hopefully by
mid next week which would be good news
as our supply increases and as we go
into the next few months we'll be able
to expand it
for symptomatic people and for people to
be able to do that type of testing
at home but the key focus in the coming
week will be as i said on supporting
k-12 and return to school
here in bc rapid tests are being used to
slow or stop outbreaks
and have to allow people to go to work
they're used as a red light to help us
understand if they're positive and that
somebody has coveted that covet is in an
area or a community they are not being
used as a
green light to allow people to socialize
as we've seen being used in other places
every rapid test has been allocated to
settings where the risk is highest and
where the test will have the greatest
impact and that has been our focus here
in british columbia with this
precious commodity that remains in short
supply both here in canada and globally
i wanted to take a few minutes to talk
about getting tested
we know and i've said this not everybody
needs a test and this week we've seen
some frustration of people wanting
access to both pcr tests and rapid tests
and
taking that out on healthcare workers in
our testing centers
please know that we have a limited
supply and we do need to use tests where
they are most appropriate to protect
people to make sure that people can go
back to essential workplaces like
healthcare workers and to be able to
identify people who may be at risk for
more severe illness so that they can get
additional treatments that they may need
so really we're focusing on people over
the age of 55
people who are pregnant people working
or living in high risk settings like
hospitals long-term care assisted living
in many remote and rural communities and
people with higher risk medical
conditions those are people who may need
these tests to help us keep them out of
hospital make sure they get the
treatments that are available as
quickly as possible
if you are fully vaccinated at lower
risk and have mild symptoms
you don't need a test
omicron is spreading widely in our
communities if you have those mild
symptoms whether it's a runny nose a
cough and you've been
out in connection with other people it's
very likely that you have covet
what you need to do is stay home and
stay away from others
and manage your symptoms and there's
information on the bccdc website about
what you can do to help get through
those symptoms over the the period of
your
infectiousness
and the period of your illness
for most people we are seeing now with
this new strain that the onset of
illness is within a very short period of
time after exposure so about three days
and that the illness is mostly mild if
you're vaccinated and you have that
level of protection
and that it tends to go away within
three to five days so we are saying to
people if you have mild illness and
you're vaccinated stay home and away
from others for five days and then you
can go about your business as long as
you're feeling better and you've no
longer have a fever or symptoms and the
things that you need to be aware of is
that you need to continue to wear a mask
when you're around other people a
well-fitting mast at all times and to
avoid those high risk settings where the
off chance that you might pass it on to
somebody else
not everybody needs a test as i've said
if they are a limited resource and we
need to use them to ensure people who
need them have access whether it's
healthcare workers and long-term care
and access to medications so that
there'll be more information coming out
and i encourage people to look at the
bccdc website to look at how you can
assess yourself for whether you have
covet or not and for those who have
rapid tests
how you can report that test
i know that for many people this is a
very challenging time of the year and
omicron has just made that even more so
for all of us
the days are cold and still short
and this has put an added burden on us
all
while decent challenges do persist
i encourage you to find that optimism
and hope that we have that we're going
through this together we have the tools
that we know work and we need to go back
and reinforce them and reinforce them
with each other
find an opportunity to go outside i know
it's very cold in many places but go
outside go for a walk or call a friend
call
a person you haven't talked to in the
last few
days or weeks connect with people we
know that connection is really important
especially this time of the year
appreciate and offer the small
kindnesses to each other that brighten
our day and make us
get through this as well
we will make it through this omicron
surge it and we will get through this
storm of this pandemic
and we'll do it together and we'll do it
as we always have by being kind and
being calm and being safe i'd now like
to turn over to minister whiteside
thank you very much
dr henry dr henry
good morning everyone my name is
jennifer whiteside i'm bc's minister of
education and it's an honor to join you
uh this morning from the traditional
territory of the musqueam slaywe tooth
and squamish peoples
i want to just to start by acknowledging
that you know we've all been living
through this pandemic for now what feels
like a lifetime and yet here we find
ourselves again in a new and very
different phase with this latest variant
you know for younger children going to
school during a pandemic is all they've
ever experienced
and for
youth older children and youth they know
full well how different
these past two years have been to other
than any before
and to all of our uh for all of our our
our school staff our educators support
staff principals vice principals our
superintendents trustees all of our
education partners
your work over the past two years has
just been extraordinary as you have put
children at the center of everything
that we do
in our k-12 system
and it's been a challenging time for all
of our school staff our district staff
our trustees for families
and of course fur for students
and i know that this is an anxious time
for parents and families
and i know that everyone on the front
lines is doing their very best as we
continue to work together to meet the
challenges posed by
by omicron
as we've shown over the last two years
our education system is ready and able
to adapt to keep our kids safe and in
school
as directed by dr henry the return to
in-class learning was postponed until
january 10th
and this has provided time for schools
and school districts to adapt to the
changing pandemic
and we have been working this week
with our k-12 education steering
committee which is made up of educators
and parents support workers school
leaders trustees indigenous rights
holders ministry staff and of course
public health experts
and we have been working with uh with
many uh superintendents and and local
school staff as well
as we experience the omicron variant
move through our communities we're
focused on protecting students and
education workers
what we know is that since the pandemic
began we have seen that schools are a
reflection of what happens in the
community and so we know
that that students and staff and our
schools will be affected uh by uh by
this latest variant and that's why we
want to ensure health and safety
measures are in place so children and
youth can learn in school to the best
extent possible and that has been the
basis of the work this week by school
districts
schools the steering committee in the
ministry and and of course public health
this preparation uh that that has been
done will mean that students can be
welcomed back to school next week to
in-person learning on monday with
additional safety measures in place
and while our goal is to have students
learning in classrooms we recognize
that there will be likely temporary
shifts
in how and where some students learn
this means that learning at home may
need to be in place for some students
over the coming weeks or months
so on monday schools will be open with
reinforced safety measures in place
including uh the provision of three
layer disposable masks which are the
masks that that look like these ones and
those are the masks that we have been
providing in schools throughout the
pandemic and we've worked to ensure that
we that districts have a have a good
supply of those masks there there will
be measures to enter to reduce crowding
to stagger break times
we will be shifting to virtual
assemblies virtual staff meetings
we will be restricting visitors to
schools for the for the time being
and i just want i would like to say
about mass that we know
that that we've been advised by public
health of course that masks are an
important layer of protection
and that students and staff will
continue to use this important layer of
protection while they're in schools and
so what monday will look like when they
when students come back to class is a
refresher on the proper way to use a
mask the importance of using a mask how
it can help keep
everybody safe as well as a refresher on
the the overall safety plan i mean we do
ask parents to send their child to
school with a three-layer mask however
we will ensure that these masks are
available at school for anyone who needs
one
and it is critical that every single day
before coming to school students
complete a daily health check staff as
well to stay home and stay home if they
have any symptoms
when it comes to communicating with the
school community what's happening with
uh with in our schools with cole when i
understand that that parents and
caregivers want to know what's happening
with coveton schools and so we have
worked with public health on a system to
ensure that we can continue to provide
communication to parents
this is going to look though very
different
from what has been in place before
because as public health has advised us
individual case management and contact
tracing is no longer a a helpful tool
for us in in tracking cases in schools
we need a proxy to understand what may
be happening with coveton schools and so
that proxy will be school attendance
schools will be monitoring attendance
rates closely and will notify public
health and the school community if
attendance dips notably below typical
rates for this time of year
and that will trigger a response from
public health which may include
investigation it might include the use
of rapid tests to get a better
understanding of what's happening on the
ground
i i do want to assure everyone that of
course our school medical health
officers work very closely with school
district leadership on a regular basis a
day-to-day basis and that of course will
continue
to help with effective information
sharing parents are encouraged to report
rapid test results to public health and
to ensure they contact the school if
their child is staying home because of
illness
by working together we will be able to
best understand what's happening in our
school communities and to determine how
and what to communicate with parents
i i want to say that i know that there
is a lot of anxiety right now and i know
that there will be bumps in the road
ahead as we navigate the next few weeks
it's a difficult time for student staff
and families and this pandemic continues
to present challenges for all of us in
our communities
the work that our schools and our
district staff have done
over this week with our partners has
helped to develop plans and prepare for
continuity of learning in the event that
a school needs to shift to home-based
learning
for a period of time
so
our goal there is to minimize the
disruption to learning to the greatest
extent possible
i want to say as well that vaccination
of course remains uh such a critical
tool to keep our schools and communities
safe and it is uh terrific and news that
so many teachers of course have been
vaccinated in bc we know uh you know the
vaccination rate amongst teachers is
upwards of 95 percent according to the
uh to the teachers federation
and we know that last year public health
prioritized many school staff for
vaccines in the in when vaccine
vaccination became available
and i understand that many teachers and
school staff will have already received
their boosters or or are in the process
of receiving their invitations to book
their booster
and you know the news of vaccinations
available for the 5 to 11
age group has been a very hopeful
development and i know continues to be a
priority
with respect to our vaccination campaign
and i strongly encourage everybody who
is eligible and parents to
to book their book their their their
appointment to uh to have their young
one vaccinated
finally i just to say that i you know we
we have really focused on ensuring we
can continue to keep kids connected to
in-person learning throughout this
pandemic
extraordinary work has happened to
achieve that goal and it's been
challenging and we're not out of the
woods yet but we have risen to meet uh
the many challenges in this pandemic and
our ongoing work together will help
ensure that students have safe spaces
and places
to learn as we work to manage the
disruption of omicron in our k-12 system
that's our goal and commitment for today
and to work to this end until we put
this pandemic behind us
thank you very much
thank you minister whiteside thank you
dr henry
today i'll be providing an update on
hospital capacity on
immunization surgical postponements and
our inventory of rapid tests
with respect to
the number of people in our hospitals
today
we have as you know
as we've discussed before
929
base beds in our health care in our
hospital system and 2 353 surge beds
we have 510 critical care based beds we
have two 818
surge critical care beds i just want to
take you through where we are as of this
morning
eight thousand seven hundred and seventy
eight uh
we have eight thousand seven hundred
seventy eight patients for our nine
thousand two hundred and twenty nine uh
base acute care beds that's
percent full
that number in itself is not surprising
it's our expectation to run at that
level in fact a year ago prior to the
two years ago i should say prior to the
covet 19 pandemic we were running at
about 103.5
on these beds so that's where we are now
with respect to the 2353 surge beds
593 of those are full at the moment for
a total of 25.2 percent with respect to
acute care beds i mean critical care
beds i should say of the 510 base beds
454
are occupied at the moment of the 218
surge beds
223 are occupied that's 89 percent and
10.6
respectively
as i've noted and as we've noted
the reason why government has taken the
ministry the provincial health officer
and the health authorities have taken
action to delay
non-urgent scheduled surgeries in these
times is in part
to ensure that we
control or limit hospital capacity so we
have space for patients with cloven 19
who may need hospital care and in
addition and just as importantly to deal
with issues of
of
medical absenteeism in other words
people who are unable
to come to work because they are sick so
it's not just an issue we have these
many beds available it's also a
significant staffing issue which is why
we're taking the steps we're taking and
we'll be taking to ensure that we have
that we limit other uses of hospital
beds in our province
with respect to immunization the last
two days
done more than administered more than
one hundred thousand of vaccines
overwhelmingly third dose vaccines in
british columbia so that's over a
hundred thousand in the last two days
fifty thousand more than fifty thousand
each day as of now um we have uh four
million three hundred ninety one nine
912 first dose immunizations and uh four
million one hundred thirty two thousand
and nine second dose immunizations
and with respect to booster doses one
million eighty nine thousand four
hundred and ten booster doses have been
administered in british columbia the
priorities have been
laid out since we announced our plan on
october 26th and by the weekend it's our
expectation that everyone who had their
second dose
more than six months ago or 182 at their
182nd day will receive an invitation to
book as you'll remember in the the uh in
previous waves in the third wave we
start when we had a the main part of our
immunization program in bc we gave
priority to essential workers in many
sectors including uh critical food
service workers obviously teachers and
others received significant priorities
so those groups of people will reach
their six months sooner than the average
population and we would be expecting
everyone to be invited to book and we
encourage people when they're invited to
book two book there remain
significant number of unfilled
appointments in bc although we are
adding significant number of people to
the system and adding appointments every
day so if you say have an appointment
for january the 25th
new appointments are going up every day
and i talk to people every day when they
check again are able to move up their
vaccine appointments and i encourage all
of you to take advantage of that
with respect to rapid tests i just want
to go through the numbers for you so
that we understand it and particularly
in light of the federal announcement
made
yesterday by
the federal minister of health mr duklow
to date just to go back and all of this
was presented
in detail on december the 21st when we
laid out our rapid test plan bc has
received three million eight hundred
ninety one thousand four hundred forty
seven rapid tests and deployed two
million seven hundred fifty two thousand
three hundred and thirty five of these
tests to key strategic areas
up until december fifteenth uh bc had
distributed 1 million 266 513 rapid
tests across five key areas long-term
care provincial corrections rural remote
and indigenous communities case contact
and cluster management and businesses
and organizations through the point of
care screening program
on december 21st we outlined a plan to
continue and expand the use of rapid
tests to cover 19 testing sites
long-term care health care workers rural
remote indigenous and vulnerable
communities businesses and organizations
and medical health officers to support
case management and outbreaks
between december 15th and january 5th we
deployed one million 485
822 tests to these areas
just over the last three weeks bc has
delivered 207 030 tests to long-term
care facilities in bc 20 000 these tests
in fact were delivered yesterday 87 000
prior to yesterday and hundred thousand
are in the process of being delivered
that leaves in bc a current inventory
of one million one hundred thirty nine
thousand one hundred and twelve tests
approximately half of the current
inventory of tests 561 672
are not suitable for deployment for take
away or personal use they require
special equipment administration by
health care professionals and cannot be
broken down or repackaged for
self-administration
these tests will continue to be used
those tests all of them will continue to
be used by medical health officers in
appropriate settings to manage clusters
and outbreaks
that leaves 577
440 tests that are more suitable for
self-administered use approximately one
for every 10 british columbians and then
there would be but of course we there
are requirements for healthcare
long-term care remote communities and
first nations and other high-risk
settings and of course as has been
described by dr henry today as we move
forward through k-12 and post-secondary
in the coming weeks
these 577 000 tests will be used for
symptomatic healthcare workers in acute
care and for cova testing sites as well
for businesses and organizations through
point of test care screening or program
the remainder in the process of being
repackaged with nasal swabs to replenish
supply testing sites and acute care
long-term care and rural remote and
indigenous communities as you'll note
yesterday canada signaled its intention
to deliver 140 million rapid tests that
have been sourced for provinces and
territories bc's share of those tests
13.5 or over eighteen million are
expected to be received through january
and february however the only tests that
have been committed to bc with certainty
are approximately six hundred thousand
tests that are expected to arrive in bc
over the next week
ninety thousand of these tests will
arrive in vancouver today
three hundred and ten thousand are on
their way and expected to arrive early
next week and a further two hundred
thousand are expected to arrive by late
next week
a hundred and twenty thousand of these
tests will be deployed as they arrive
directly to health authorities for use
by symptomatic healthcare workers in
acute care
two hundred and eighty thousand will
require processing and repackaging as
they arrive and will be rapidly deployed
on a daily basis to testing sites across
bc
the two hundred thousand arriving late
next week will be used by symptomatic
teachers and school staff
dr henry and minister whiteside spoke to
reinforce safety measures in place for
schools i can add that the ministries of
health and education will work with the
bccdc and school districts over the next
weeks to determine the best approach to
distribute these new tests arriving late
next week and to establish clear
protocols for self-testing
as our supply increases in mid to late
january we will expand the availability
of rapid tests
across
education systems
we will continue to update the public on
the deployment and use of rapid tests as
we gain certainty on timing and supply
from the federal government it is
important to remember that the
announcement by the federal government
that tens of millions of rapid tests
have been secured does not mean they
have been arrived been delivered or are
ready for use in bc
and it's important to recognize that we
are very obviously pleased that the
federal government has made this effort
but they are not here yet
and now
here's our weekly surgical renewal
update health authorities report from
december 5th to december 11th that's
7040 surgeries were completed in bc
which is a remarkable achievement by
surgeons by nurses by health sciences
professionals by healthcare workers in
bc
while urgent and non-urgent scheduled
surgeries are continuing around the
province over the holiday period health
authorities postponed in that period
december 26 to january 1st
38 non-urgent scheduled surgeries that's
two in fraser health five in vancouver
coastal health four in northern health
27 in interior health
cumulatively from september 5th to
january 1st there have been 4029
surgical postponements due to regional
surges of covet and factors including
severe weather patterns patients are
anticipating their surgery and are
anxious about it and are ready to make
that next step everyone involved in
delivering surgeries and by now i think
all of us really understands that no
patient ever wants to receive a call
postponing their surgery almost two
years ago when our first fulfillment
started we made a commitment right then
we said you were not forgotten right
then we said we will you we will get you
your surgery and that is exactly what we
did and that's exactly what we'll
continue to do
several times now the persistence of a
virus that spreads to live has perhaps
tempted us to dwell on what we can't do
yet each time we've responded by
focusing on all that we can do together
using the power and the ability we have
to loosen kovitz hold
i want to express my appreciation to
healthcare workers in testing in
vaccination and acute care in the
community who are doing exceptional work
and i want to express my appreciation to
everyone in bc who is i believe doing
their part
to help all of us help each other help
our friends our neighbors to care for
one another in the covet 19 pandemic to
use the the tools and the power that we
have
to address a very challenging time in
the world
over the last uh seven days test
positivity in bc has run about 24
percent in cloven 19. it's been
relatively stable on a day-to-day
average but it's been stable at a very
very high level through more than a
hundred thousand pcr tests so an
exceptional sample of where we are in
british columbia with respect to the
pandemic that is very high test
positivity rates you recall the
beginning of december those test
positive rates positivity rates were
about three percent so eight times
higher than that
in in this period it's going to require
more of us unfortunately because i know
all of you and all of us are tired but
we can do this together and we must do
this together to do all of the things
that you need to do
to reduce the transmission in covid19
because all of the things you can do
help our health care workers our
hospitals our schools everyone i want to
thank you for all you've done so far and
i would
we are
happy to take your questions
a reminder to media on the line please
press star one to enter the queue you'll
be limited to one question and one
follow-up our first question today comes
from zhao zhu globe and mail
uh hi dr harry uh infection disease
expert at stanford and uh
[Music]
your guidance earlier this week that
n95 max offer only incremental
protection to people in settings like
stores or schools is wrong they said
with omnicorn
uh respirators uh are needed in crowded
indoor uh public settings and a 2010 uh
peer review study showed more than three
quarters of people putting known uh a
respirator for the first time did so
properly and provide themselves better
protection uh than what surgical macs do
achieve what do you say to these experts
criticizing your stance and are you
reconsidering
offering students teachers or health
workers free and 95 if not why not and
minister uh white side the bctf wants
free and 95s for anyone who wants them
why won't your ministry offer this
thanks
so i think we need to put things into
perspective
and
look at w.h.o documents look at
what we know about how things are
transmitted in public settings so
outside of healthcare settings and
schools are a very good example we have
many many things in place that make it
very unlikely that viruses and other
pathogens will be transmitted in schools
with the things that we have in place
now one of the most important things and
i would put this back to those experts
is about having layers of protection and
a hierarchy of protection which means
you have things like reduced numbers of
people you have things like
reducing the mixing and mingling of
people you have the same people going
back to a class every day so you're not
mixing with numbers of different people
at different times you have other things
that are important to try and prevent
the entrance of a hazard into that
setting like the daily screenings we do
so you can't become infected if there's
nobody with the virus in the setting so
there are many things that we do in
these structured settings to make sure
that you don't have to rely on the
moderately increased filtration
capacity of a respirator versus a
medical mask
and i think we need to be pragmatic and
practical as well we know that we're not
seeing explosive outbreaks of this virus
in those settings where we have these
things in place that is a fact
and we know that the best mask that you
wear is a good quality one that is well
fitting to your face
and i would just reiterate that's the
important thing it's not the mask is is
one piece of many prongs that we have in
many different settings
that protect people from transmission of
viruses so it's everything that we do
that makes a difference so that you
don't have to rely on
the increased filtration of a respirator
versus a surgical mask and in
school settings in the public settings
outside of healthcare settings it's much
more important that you have a good
quality good fitting mask that you wear
and that you wear consistently and that
you wear correctly
we'll now go to vancouver for the rest
of the response
thank you and really thank you and
really just to add to um to dr henry's
comments to say that
in the education sector we work very
closely and
under the advice and direction of
our public health advisors at the cdc
and the advice that we've received in
the sector is to ensure that we can
provide the uh the three the the the
three layer disposable masks throughout
our system and to importantly uh ensure
that we're reinforcing that message and
that that working with students uh to
ensure that there's appropriate use of
masks and that they're available and
we've been working with our suppliers to
ensure that there is that there's a good
supply of masks available next week when
kids come back to school thank you
yes i do thanks uh you've mentioned you
will no longer report school outbreaks
and instead will monitor attendance and
if it dips blow then the school will
contact public health how will
parents know if their child has been
exposed to a sick child and how will
parents know if there has been an
outbreak at their school at what point
will a school refer to online learning
and is that the only way parents will
know if there has been an outbreak
thanks
i think that they just
start and turn it back and turn it back
to uh dr henry just with respect to the
reporting of exposures and and such uh
what what we understand uh uh in the
current situation that we're in with
omicron is that in under having access
to information about individual test
positive cases is is not going to be
possible so we need a proxy to
understand what's happening in schools
so schools know very well what their
attendance rates are and how they
fluctuate fluctuate and what what they
what is typical for this time of year so
schools will be monitoring on a daily
basis as they always do
for that for attendance as a trigger and
when it reaches a certain point that
will be a trigger to say that there's
something going on in a classroom or
across a grade or in a school and that
requires an intervention by by public
health when a school notifies
public health that there is a sort of
what we might call a signal of concern
with respect to attendance the a
notification will also go out to the
school community the school community
will know when a school has notified
public health that there's that there's
a matter for
for concern and with respect to uh to a
shift to home-based learning that is a
decision a call that
that schools will make based on their
assessment of what is uh what is
happening with their with their own
workforce in terms of
are there do they do they have enough
enough staff to be able to operate the
school
to operate classes uh safely and so
those again are situations where likely
the decision will be made quickly but
parents would be notified that that was
to that that will happen there will be a
short time for transition and then
home-based learning will will commence
and those are the very plans that
schools have been developing and and are
ready to to put in place that's been
part of the work of this this week and
perhaps i can turn it back to dr henry
for the question about about exposure no
thank you i think that summarized it
really well and just to to be very clear
we are always going to
notify parents of outbreaks that is not
changed and that's what we do for other
respiratory infections measles in
classrooms or in in school settings
other
outbreaks that happen as well so it is
not going to change that and how we'll
understand if they're outbreaks is by
monitoring things like uh attendance and
people
both staff and students who are off ill
so that continues and remains in place
what we are no longer able to do and
makes uh is not um
right now is those individual case
exposures that were being notified um
over the past couple of of months and
years so it because of the way this is
transmitting so rapidly and we are no
longer doing individual case and contact
tracing in the community because of the
change in the parameters that we're
seeing with omicron it's not effective
to do that because of the short
incubation period and the rapid
transmission so we cannot rely on
individual case and contact tracing so
that is why we're not we're no longer be
able to do
individual
case exposure notifications in schools
so that will change and it will change
to be
trying to understand if there's a risk
of an outbreak and being able to take
action
if we see absenteeism increase so those
are the the changes that are
necessitated by the way that this new
strain of the virus is transmitting
thank you very much and a reminder to
media on the line please do limit
yourselves to one question and one
follow-up that will allow us to get to
as many of your colleagues as possible
our next question goes to sinjan
alexander ctv
we are good afternoon everyone this
question i guess is for dr henry and mr
dicks
i'm hoping you can help me
understand the definition of outbreak
especially in care homes and acute care
what do you consider an outbreak is
we're also hearing that it's really just
for an uncontrolled spread is that true
it's only for an uncontrolled spread
that's what you consider an outbreak or
or what do you consider an outbreak
so we have had an outbreak in long-term
care and acute care has been defined for
covid for some time and it is
more than one
staff person depending on the situation
or a single resident or patient who's
tested positive for covet 19. so that's
what triggers a single staff person
triggers
an enhanced monitoring and testing and
if more people turn up positive then
that is declared an outbreak but a
single resident case or patient case
means that somehow there's been
transmission within that setting so
that's where an outbreak is declared
do you have a follow-up sinjin
i do uh thank you
i'm also looking at i know you were
talking a lot about
the hospitals and shortage of staff
there and uh i know there's some doctors
nurses who are covered positive and
there's a lot of talk about whether they
should be allowed back in the hospital
to help
treat patients and and do their work
where are you in that will you allow
doctors and nurses who are covered
positive to work again
so i've said this
quite a few times but i'll say it again
we have health human resource planning
in place
right now
that has been since the very beginning
we have principles that we use
things like calling people back from
vacation and time off extending hours
having people work in different areas so
there's a whole series of things that we
do to try and manage
when when people are off ill as covet is
spreading through the community so these
things have been in play and are
continuing to be put in place
one of the last resort if we get to that
point where
we are
it will compromise
care for people then we might be
find so we have a fitness for work
protocol it's called for health care
workers who are infected with omicron
who have very mild symptoms or are
asymptomatic
and they can come back under certain
conditions if needed so as as i've said
a number of times this is a last resort
we of course do not want to have people
who are ill working for a whole variety
of reasons for their own health and as
well uh the risk that it brings to the
setting so there are protocols in place
for when it might be needed and where
people would work for example we would
not have somebody who has
had mild cases of covert working on a
cancer ward they would work properly
with covet patients for example so those
are things that we have protocols in
place that have been
dusted off again to make sure that if we
get to that point
we have a process that allows
if necessary
people to work if they have mild illness
and they're able to work
now over to minister dixon vancouver
just to say that this is why we made the
decision
a number of weeks ago now
that as of january 4th we were going to
delay
non-urgent scheduled surgeries in our
province we're obviously assessing that
on a week-to-week basis but
that's one of the ways we have and it
comes at a price
but it's one of the ways that we have
to reduce the number of people in the
hospital and allow us to use our staff
more effectively to deal with the
circumstance of the omicron variant of
concern
in long-term care and in and in acute
care there is significant planning
that's taken place at every stage of the
pandemic you'll note in august of 2020
we announced a plan and a detailed plan
of our health human resources strategies
for that fall and winter
and
unfortunately in that fall and winter we
saw fewer for example influenza cases
than we typically see the challenge in
january is that there is typically more
people in our hospitals in in january
such that in this date
before the clover pandemic in 2019 there
were well over 100 of base beds full at
that time there are more other kinds of
illness more people dealing with things
such as influenza but other
respiratory illness particularly
vulnerable people and other conditions
that people are facing so that's why
we're taking we've taken action in the
areas that we have control to give
ourselves the best chance to deal with
this so what you're talking about is
something that might be envisioned at
some point in the future in order to
address something but right now the
current rules and the continuing rules
apply we want people who are sick to
stay home
the next question we go to uh richard
sussman global news
part of the anxiousness people are
feeling is around sort of a lack of
specifics so
on this trigger that you mentioned in
terms of dropping below attendance what
creates the trigger
and the other thing i've heard from a
lot of people in the system
is at what point does a school close for
functional reasons is it
20 percent of staff not available 30
percent of staff not available what
point does a functional closure get
triggered
and for families they are concerned
about when they even send their kids
back so
when is it safe if you have coveted
symptoms but can't access a test
when can you send your child back to
school
if you're 5 to 11 does it even matter if
they've received a vaccine or not
so perhaps i'll i'll start and then uh
minister whiteside can uh can respond as
well
yeah you know this has been a really
challenging thing for parents all along
is you know is it is is it kovitch
should i keep them home is it that runny
nose that's been going on for a long
time so those decisions right now are
will continue to be those challenging
ones i would say if in doubt
keep your child home right now and yes
it does make a huge difference if
they're vaccinated especially the 5 to
11 and i encourage all young people to
get vaccinated we know and we're seeing
increasing evidence you know omicron
does affect younger people and it's more
upper airway and there's some concern
that it can exacerbate asthma more
likely than some of the other variants
that we've seen so far so that there is
good protection even after dose one it
it helps
so that is important to get children
protected from getting sick from this
and yes it's going to be a challenging
thing as we you know get more and more
hopefully of the at-home tests available
we'll be able to support families in
being able to do that and that's
something that i've been wanting to do
for a long time but we have not yet had
those types of tests available in canada
or in bc so that is coming but it's not
going to get us through this next few
weeks we need to continue to use your
good judgment and you know parents know
kids
and if and don't keep them home for a
day if it's getting better and resolving
then you can go back into school so
that's how we're going to have to manage
this through this next little while
um the in terms of the the cutoffs and
when uh the absenteeism we're looking at
ten percent above normal and
these are things that will vary a little
bit depending on the school and the
district and um how they're able to
bring other people in to support so
there's no one cut off in terms of
what would lead to a functional closure
and i think minister whiteside can
address that in more detail but each
each principal each school each school
staff they understand the regular
pattern of absenteeism in their in our
kids who are off sick
staff absenteeism in their schools and
and the patterns that they see so we've
been working we in public health have
been working with them to to have the
protocols that are in place to support
administrators and to connect when they
have a concern so that we can help in
the investigation of determining exactly
what's happening in that school and
minister did you want to add to that
do you want to add to that
yes thank you thank you dr henry and
thank you richard for the question uh
and i just to reinforce you know
educators know their classrooms
principles and vice principals know
their schools and superintendents know
their districts
so they know what is a general level of
of absence on any day in the system
where a number of students and staff
would be
would not be at school for a number of
different kinds of reasons so they know
what that what that level is and if it's
90 percent and their and their
attendance drops you know down towards
80 percent then that that will be a
trigger
but they will also be monitoring on a
daily basis to understand and to see
what what is what what's happening in in
their school
and if that trigger is you know if
absenteeism is if attendance or rather
is is higher or slightly lower
that is the um that that is what the
what a school will use to assess to help
assess what's uh what what where whether
there is a what we're what we're calling
a signal of of concern that that needs
attention from from public health
with respect to functional closures you
know it will look different from
district to district we have a we have
you know almost sixteen hundred public
schools um in the system over three
hundred independent schools we have a
lot of different sizes and varieties and
shapes of schools and so it's different
in a school of
of 300 students versus a school of
18 or 1900 students in in surrey the
superintendent has said that generally
when they're looking at a staff abs
absentee rate of around 25 percent if
they have 25 or so of their of their
staff out with uh with illness then
that's going to be a challenge for them
to to um to operate some of their
schools so all districts are
superintendents they're looking at that
question but it will be diff a bit
different from district to district and
uh schools are going to be working very
hard to communicate with parents in
their school communities as we move
through the the coming weeks
richard do you have a follow-up dr henry
with the announcement today around the
coveted safety plans how quickly do they
come into place and did this have
anything
to do with the announcement we found out
today that the canucks uh would be
postponing uh their game tomorrow like
was there any conversation with the team
that uh there was going to be a
reduction in capacity or or change in
rules that made it impossible for the
team uh to operate and and for minister
dix uh with the concerns yesterday at
the convention center people waiting uh
more than two hours uh to get their
vaccine have changes been made there and
are you worried about the fact that
hundreds of thousands of people will be
hitting six months in the next few weeks
and
we just don't have the capacity there
yet to manage this influx that's coming
so i guess i'll start in terms of the
covet safety plans um i've been engaged
with many different sectors and industry
sectors as have some of our team over
the last few weeks and many of the the
sectors i think of the the food
processing plants for example um they
really embraced uh the
uh
the the measures that were put in place
and continue to have them in place i
know in some places and some retail
places they've taken away some of the
barriers and they've changed things so
it is a move to go back to those it will
be an order as i've said and
we'll be transitioning to to getting
those back it's a consultative process
as well and that's part of the
how they have worked so well it's
between the employer and the employees
and it will be publicly posted and so i
will say
to people who are used to
not having to do things
in the last little while that we're in a
new phase again and we need to go back
to being mindful of numbers of people
that were are in a setting wearing masks
making sure that we are wearing our mask
and if we can't um finding alternate
ways to get the things that we need
whether that's curbside or ordering
online
because this is an important time to
protect workers in those settings and to
make sure that we have those things in
place that help preserve the
health care work for the the the workers
in those settings and and keep them from
being
exposed additionally within their
workplace setting so they will come into
place
in the next uh i expect there'll be a
bit of a transition for some
businesses and some of them will already
have things in place already
we're working with worksafebc and the
the information is
is out there so over the coming week i
expect these to be up in and in place
across
industries across the province
in terms of the canucks we've had an
ongoing discussions i've said this
before
supporting their safe operations and it
was a decision i provided advice but it
was a decision that they made
to
postpone both the last game in this game
given the situation that we're faced
with here and the situation they're
faced with in the nhl as well
now over to vancouver
thank you
thank you richard
i would say that we've seen
a significant increase in capacity to
meet
all of those people who are at the
six-month point or or or longer in the
last couple of three days
142 000 vaccines administered in three
days 101 000 over the last two days
including yesterday at the convention
center 5 000. now at the convention
center there's two sets of things to
remember we ramped that up from zero to
five thousand very quickly and that was
i think
reflects the extraordinary work done by
our bc immunization teams a significant
number of people at the convention
center yesterday and it caused a bit of
a challenge for us and for people
but one in four of the people that we
surveyed did not have an appointment you
can only get a third dose
vaccination if you get if you have an
appointment and that makes the system
work better for everybody and we've got
to communicate that and that's what i'm
doing today so there are some places
where you can get a drop in for a first
and second dose there are no drop ins
for third doses the good news is that
there are hundreds of hundreds of
thousands of open appointments such that
yesterday a
constituent of mine got an appointment
uh for
saturday on tuesday uh
or i guess yesterday was well yes it was
wednesday i think i forget what day of
the week we are now but uh friday right
but uh yesterday in any event got one
for saturday so we have lots of
appointments that are coming available
and going to be coming available so we
are raising the capacity of the system
to meet this challenge and i am
confident we're going to be able to do
it our teams didn't have done an
exceptional job over the last couple of
days i apologize to people who waited uh
in line for a couple of hours at the
convention center but also thank them
for their perseverance for getting
through and for getting their booster
dose it's important when you're invited
to get your booster dose to get it and
finally i just want to say in addition
to all of that we are doing obviously an
immunization program for children 511
with the 5 to 11 with the specialized
design for them pediatric vaccine
against covet 19
and to date 140
711 children 5 to 11 have received their
vaccination
166 000 have received
or and have booked an appointment and a
total of 182 000 have registered now
that leaves approximately 167 000
children who have not yet been
registered in the system i encourage
them to do so we have about 90 centers
around bc that are that have the
pediatric
vaccine the pfizer pediatric vaccine for
children 5 to 11 designed for them and i
encourage every single one of those
parents to register their children today
for the next question we go to lisa
kordasco vancouver thank you very much
um
dr henry i'd like to know what changed
uh from last week when you didn't want
to
start or begin any orders on businesses
and
without an accurate dot account on case
count numbers how would you be able to
tell if your orders are working
yeah so a couple of things i think there
was some um
when i said i wanted to get out of the
order business that was about getting
through this pandemic that we don't want
to have orders that require us to do
certain things
and they are a function of
of how we've had to manage to get
through this pandemic and i stand by
that and we want to do this few orders
as possible and yes we you know orders
closing businesses down are things that
i don't want to do and i absolutely
don't want to do
but we do
take to take them very seriously and
they they are orders
what i talked about last week was or
earlier this week was the least
restrictive means the things that we can
do that will um the minimum amount of
disruption to accomplish what we need to
do which is to minimize sickness and and
death to min to protect our health care
system and to minimize the disruption
that we're causing on society especially
the negative disruption so
this is uh
one of the things that we has worked for
us in the past and and consultation with
industry it makes it much cleaner if we
have an order and that it lays out all
of the the requirements under the order
so that's why we're doing it i
didn't mean to imply in any way that i
wouldn't do orders if they were
necessary it's mostly
we want to get through this part so that
we can come back to learning how to live
with this as another respiratory virus
in our lives and we're not there yet but
i do think we will get there and we'll
we'll get there as as you know as we get
through this this wave and hopefully
into the spring i think it's going to be
a very different situation for us and
and i won't need to to put in orders
anymore
um and i'm sorry i lost the second piece
of what you said
how how difficult is it to judge whether
the orders are working if
you know the data you're able to collect
on case count
yeah so case counts have only been one
thing that we've and and to be honest
we've been trying to move away from the
daily case counts as an indicator of
what's happening
because they only reflect uh case rates
and testing rates in different areas so
it's one of the surveillance markers
that we use and it's very consistent so
we've been using the pcr daily case
counts but really as we introduced
over a year ago that the seven day
rolling average gives us a better sense
because that
takes into account um daily variations
that we see in different testing centers
and testing sites so it is one indicator
but it's not the only one by any means
things like we talk about quite a bit
the percent positivity so that is a
marker that tells us over time
in a number of our modeling sessions i
present a number of other things that we
look at whether it's hospitalizations
icu the percent of of testing the rate
of testing sorry and different age
groups in different communities that
helps us unders put the testing and the
data counts in perspective
we are also
we have an online reporting for rapid
antigen test positivity and that's
expanding it's going to be available by
early next week for everybody in the
province and we are getting some
information from that it is limited
because we don't have a denominator we
don't know how many people actually are
using it but it does give us a sense of
what proportion of of tests that are
reported are positive out of the ones
that we've distributed so it's an
imperfect marker uh i talked a lot about
uh in our last modeling about the
wastewater surveillance that we're doing
in a number of different areas so
there's many different streams of
surveillance that help us give it get an
understanding of
of what actually is happening with the
pandemic and the trajectory of the
pandemic in the in bc
now over to minister dixon vancouver
vancouver i just uh want to note
on this point that
dr henry our teams in public health
brought in new orders december 20th
december 23rd december 29th and december
31st
so there's no reluctance to use their
web use orders where they're designed to
help people and to
reduce the transmission of covet 19 and
dr henry has demonstrated that what i
know from from my observations and our
engagement with public health is that
every time that step is taken
every time dr henry considers the
consequences of that the consequences of
the order mental health and otherwise
and business classes all the
consequences before taking the order
every one of those orders is taken with
reluctance it is taken with reluctance
the limitation of visitation to
long-term care because we understand
i understand dr henry understands the
consequences of that
but the action was taken because it was
necessary to take that action and i
think the process and the work of dr
henry and our team in this area is just
exemplary i'm very proud of them and i'm
very proud of their approach which is to
use all of the layers of protection to
use orders when necessary and understand
that all of those orders have
consequences other than on covet 19.
dr henry and waste of water and
monitoring um in your response uh will
you share publicly the data that you're
collecting on rapid tests uh where
people register through the website and
and can you explain why the data on
wastewater testing has not been updated
on the website since december the 20th
uh i think it's the 24th that it wasn't
updated yeah absolutely we're collating
that and i'm trying to understand what
it means and i fully intend to
to make it public once we have an
understanding of how to best present
that and what how to interpret it these
are not easy things to interpret as i
mentioned i'm talking about sorry the
the online reporting of rapid antigen
test positivity and so uh it there's
complications when you don't have a
denominator and if we look at the uk for
example um this is
a model for how they've been using
at-home tests for a long time and they
have a qr code and you can download but
they don't have a sense of how many
people are actually using the tests and
how many people are actually reporting
online so it's tricky to to know what it
actually tells you so we're working
to come up with a framework to
understand what it means and yes i'll be
absolutely representing that and the
reason that there was a pause in some of
the reporting of the wastewater
surveillances because
particularly at the the wastewater sites
it takes time and people to do the the
type of testing and they uh those people
needed a break over the holidays so they
spent time with their families and we
suspended
some of the data
collection for a short period of time
but that's been
now that they've been able to have a
little bit of time
as we
know a lot of people have been working
very long hours and including our
laboratory staff so those uh that
surveillance will be continuing
next question christopher folds kamloops
this week
hi uh thanks for this uh opportunity um
i i just spoke with a employee of a
long-term care home here in kamloops and
um
they say and i i want to clarify this is
the right policy they say they they they
give rapid tests to essential visitors
but the visitor then just goes in and
visits while they the employee waits for
the results of the test that takes about
15 minutes they said there is three
today in which the uh the essential
visitor does the rapid test then goes
into visit
and i said that doesn't make any sense
and the employee says even if it's
positive they're allowed to go in
because the rapid tests aren't as
reliable in the omicron detection is
this the policy or is she wrong
that's not a the policy that we would
have in place no i think that's a a
loose interpretation of the policy and
so i would encourage them to review
their protocols that they have in place
and
i know that we've been working with the
care homes and how to how to put those
protocols in place across the province
in the last little while
chris do you have a follow up
yeah
you talked about you know whether uh the
rapid tests are
as good for omicron and there's
limitations to the rapid tests and
heaven knows i've said that a few times
before
but if they are positive it is a good
indication that you should not be
visiting that day
and
depending on the person they may need to
to have another test
but
there is some
concerns out there that
delta is better detected by an np or a
nasal swab and omicron might be better
detected by a throat swab it's mostly
theoretical right now
and the nasal swabs that we have and the
rapid tests that we have seem to be
working just as well from what we can
tell for omicron as for delta and the
other strains that we're seeing so not
perfect by any means
but still the nasal swab is the way that
we would recommend doing it right now
there is some in the lab circles uh
discussions about whether you do a
throat and a nasal at with the same swab
but
for now uh the data that we have
supports that using them with the nasal
swab right now is is as good as we can
do right now
chris do you have a follow-up
unrelated follow-up that's to uh with
hospital hospitalizations of covet
patients can you clarify how they are
counted as covet patients if a person
goes to the hospital for
non-covet-related matter let's say
a car accident they have broken bones
but in the course of being admitted they
test positive for covet even though
they're asymptomatic are they then
counted as a covet patient or are clovid
patients only counted when they go there
and they're really sick and they have to
go in the hospital yeah and so this is
something that um
is i've talked about a few times before
as well there's several different ways
that we look at uh hospitalization with
covid and
um
and we are working through it as our
colleagues across the country and we had
a discussion on our chief medical
officer of health call about this very
thing
especially now where we're trying to
understand the severity of illness with
omicron so we're trying to tease apart
people who are in hospital from covet
people who are in hospital with covid
and people who are in hospital because
kovid
exacerbated one of their underlying
conditions and it's not easy to do that
except by going and looking at every
individual chart so we have several ways
that we are measuring right now
hospitalization and we're in the process
of of looking at how we can make this
more
more automated more streamlined less
people intensive and give us a sense of
what we need to know so we are we are
right now measuring two different things
one of them is everybody in a hospital
in a facility with a covet positive test
so that will be a mixture of people who
came in for something else and were
screened for surgery for example for you
know somebody who had trauma who was
going for surgery might have had a covet
screen and had a positive test people
who
we have a couple of outbreaks right now
in acute care and people who were
involved in the outbreak so they were in
hospital for something else
and they tested positive as part of the
outbreak people who are actually truly
in hospital because kovid made them sick
enough to require hospital care
so it is an overestimation of the burden
that omicron is is causing
but it is a number that we get it's not
a hundred percent um accurate every
single day because it relies on people
counting who's in every single hospital
and then collating that information so
that's one of the uh measures that we
get another one that we that takes even
more information is uh looking at
everybody who's tested positive for
covin 19 and that's based on our
laboratory pcr testing and epidemiologic
link testing and then looking at how
many of them in the course of their
illness require hospitalization
so that is a measure of how severe is
the illness on average and that's an
important measure we want to know for
omicron compared to delta for example
but that recall requires linkage of
information from the laboratory
from the on the individual with
hospitalization
lists and so it takes more time to do
that and it takes a little bit of a
delay so what we're working on and what
we've been
presenting is a bit of a composite of
both of those
uh pieces of information which are
collected for two different reasons and
we're in the process right now of trying
to tease through what's the best measure
for us to understand the impact of
omicron on
on severity of illness and on
hospitalizations so we'll have more to
say about that
in the coming week and i know i've been
sharing this this these discussions with
my colleagues in ontario and alberta
because we're all trying to struggle
with some of those measures
we have time for one more question we'll
go to bell peary cbc
thank you and uh in english and french
please dr henry uh you and richard
talked about you know students getting
sick but i want to ask you um it's
probably safe to say that uh right now
many students have family members who
have covered at home but the students
don't have any symptoms the children
don't have any symptoms
can those children students go to school
like what's your guidance for families
dealing with covet in their households
right now
yeah so i i think
the the short answer is yes
we are
particularly children with mild illness
and less likely to to
have symptoms um yes we are still
allowing children to go to school
in those settings and to be to monitor
very carefully if there's a really sick
people in the house and
you know it may be up to
families to make those decisions about
whether they want to keep children home
in those scenarios
now we'll go to vancouver for minister
dicks
[Music]
dr henry
[Music]
the proprietary person on a system
the test on the province is important
on two circumstances
i thought about this of course the
important things are are making sure
that they're wearing a mask when they're
in school that they uh
are doing all of the other things that
uh help prevent transmission of
infections
do you have a follow-up bill
yes please and again in english and
french dr henry the bc cdc has new
testing advice on its website and it
suggests that people with a couple of
symptoms for more than 24 hours should
get tested now that seems to contradict
what you just said about not needing a
test if you only have mild symptoms
so
the
the guidance on the bccdc website talks
about the types of symptoms but we also
put that in the context of whether
you're
vaccinated or not vaccinated and your
risk so
we are in the process of updating that
but i thought it had been changed
but really it right now with the type of
illness we're seeing and with the rapid
transmission and the finite capacity
that we have to do particularly pcr
testing
that if you don't have severe illness
you're not immunocompromised and you're
vaccinated and you have a mild illness
you don't need a test right now
and over to vancouver minister dicks
dr henry
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr henry and i
will see you next tuesday
thank you